Let's take a look at some examples
tasks we use
information to make equations to solve our problem
task, after which we will actually solve the problem.
Let's get to Task 1.
Write a mathematical equation that describes it
the relationship between the variables in the table.
Here we have days and profits.
And if we look at them, on the first day the profit is 20, the second-
40, and the third 60.
It does not matter what's going on, the profit always
will be equal to-let's see, at 20, 40, 60, 80.
It looks like every day it grew by 20.
That's plus 20, out of 20 goes to 40, then plus 20, plus
20, plus 20.
So every day there is an increase of 20.
Maybe the formula here is that our profit is equal to
the day, multiplied by 20, is equal to 20 times a day.
Does this match the data?
Let's see, we could try with all of them, but when
the day is 5, 20 times 5 is 100.
5 times 20 is 100.
Yes, it does seem, in fact, this coincides with the data.
And if we want to record it in a slightly more algebraic way,
we could say that the gain is q, and the day is d,
and we will write our equation, with the gain equal to 20 times d or 20d.
And that's part a.
I wrote a mathematical equation that describes it
connection.
Next part b, ask us what is the profit on the tenth day?
Well, for our luck we have written our equation, so
actually ask us what is happening with p,
the profit, what happens to the profit when d or day is equal to 10?
So the profit will be 20 times a day,
in which we are, day 10.
20 times 10, which is equal to 200.
It is.
Task 3.
Write a mathematical equation for the following
situations and to solve it.
So let's look at part a.
7 times a given number makes 35.
What is the number?
So every time I say a number, I'll use it
the variable x.
I could use any variable, I could say y
or b, or z or whatever.
But I'm going to use x because I'm mostly used to this,
and is used in principle, unless
we have not already used x.
So, 7 times the number, I'll say 7 times x is equal to 35.
This is our equation.
We have written our mathematical equation.
And now it is, what is the number?
To find x, we can use one of two ways.
We can divide the two sides from the equation to 7.
If we divide this side to 7, and that side to the 7th
the whole reason I do this is because I want this one
factor to become 1.
And what I'm doing on one side of the equation, I have to do it
on the other side.
So 7, divided by 7 is 1, so we have 1h or we have only
x, equal to 35, divided by 7.
x is equal to 5.
The other way we could think about it, we could
let's say we multiply both sides
of the equation by 1/7.
So we have 1/7 times 7x equal to 35 times 1/7.
These are two tangible ways to do this.
Either way, these would be shortened.
We would get 1 x equal to 5.
And now
part b.
A number is 25 times greater than 2 times by another number.
Well, let's say x is equal to one
number, one number.
Let us say that y is equal
the other number.
So here we have more variables introduced.
So one number, say x, e-e, looks like equality-
is equal to 25 more than 2 times by another number.
Well, this is the other number.
We have 2 times on our other number.
This is the result of this first order here.
One number is 25 more than twice the other number.
2 times the other number plus 25 will be equal to mine
first number.
So, let's see now.
If each number is multiplied by 5, the sum of all will be 350.
And that means 5 times that plus 5 times what it will be
equal to 350.
And 5 times x plus 5 times y will be equal to 350.
He asks what the numbers are.
Well here we can do something called substitution.
We have already seen that x is equal to the whole thing here.
As if we say x is equal to 5 or x equals 9
or the like.
x is equal to something.
And every time we see x, we can replace it
with this "thing."
We see one here, so we can replace it with that
something, and then we will have an equation that contains only one y
and then we can find y.
And this can be written as 5 times, instead of one x we ​​have
all this here, 25 plus 2.
I replaced x because we know x is equal to
of all this.
25 plus 2y plus 5u equals 350.
We use the distribution property.
5 times 25 gives 125, plus 5 times 2u is 10 y, plus all,
5u equals 350.
10u plus 5u is 15u.
This is 15u plus 125, equal to 350.
Now we can get 125 on both sides, so minus 125-
Excuse me, minus 125.
I do this to get rid of 125
on the left side.
And our equation is simplified - I will continue here above.
We obtain that 15u is equal to 350 minus 125.
This is equal to 225.
And maybe you already know or do not know that 15 times 15 is 225,
so we already know how y y is.
Let's divide the two sides to 15 to get up
clearly what I do.
We divide the two sides to 15, and we get that y equals 225 on
15, which is equal to 15.
But we are not ready yet.
We know how long it is, but we're still looking for x.
Thus x is equal to 25 plus 2 times y.
y is equal to 15.
2 times 15, this gives 30.
25 plus 30 is 55.
Now let's pass on part with.
I'm excited
this here.
This too.
Part
p.
The sum of two consecutive integers is 35.
What are the numbers?
So, let's say x is equal
the first integer.
Then how much will be the second number?
Well, the second number will be
with 1 greater than the first one.
They are consistent, one comes after the other.
So x plus 1 is equal to the second number.
We are also told that the sum of these two numbers is 35.
So x plus the number that comes after x, x plus 1,
is equal to 35.
We collect these two, and we get that 2x plus 1 equals 35.
We take 1 on either side of the equation, we get that 2x
is equal to 34 - just pulled out 1 on both sides.
We divide the two sides to 2 and we get that x equal to 17.
So the first number is 17 and the second number is only one
greater, it is 18.
And notice, these are two consecutive integers, 17 and 18, like them
assemble, we get 35.
Part
d.
Peter is 3 times older than his age 6 years ago.
How old is Peter?
Thus, Peter - I will use p for Peter's age - he is equal to
3 times the age of 6 years ago.
How old was she 6 years ago?
Well, if he is now at the age of years, he was at the minus 6
three years ago.
Let me write this as a p minus 6 -this is older than that
6 years ago.
This means a minus 6.
This 3 times is the three times he is older with
of his age 6 years ago.
And, of course, that's his age at the moment.
So we have to find q.
And we get that p is equal to, we divide the threes, 3 times the r
is 3p minus 3, multiplied by 6 is 18.
Now we can draw 3p on both sides of the equation.
We get minus 2p, right? p minus 3p gives a minus, or
negative sign, 2p is equal to minus 18.
And by dividing the two sides into minus 2, we get that r
is equal to 9.
We only multiply both sides by minus 2,
and we can check it out.
Now he is 9.
Six years ago he was 3, and is now 3 times older than that.
Well, 6 years ago he was 3, and at the age of 9 he was 3
times older than his age 6 years ago.
So it definitely works.
That's the good of the algebra, you always can
to check his job.
It is always clear when we received the correct answer.
Task 6.
The cost of an MP3 player has dropped to 20% from the previous one
year to this year.
This year, the player's cost is $ 120.
What was his price last year?
Let's say p is the price last year.
The fact is that the cost of an MP3 player
has been reduced to 20% from last year until this year.
Let's calculate 20% of that.
Thus, the price minus 20% of it - this is a reduction
with 20% - is equal to the price this year we know,
that is $ 120.
How much is p minus 0.2 or minus 20% of p?
We have reduced by 20%.
And we will have 80% left.
So we can say that 80% of the price last year are equal to
the price of this year.
As we have already done, we divide the two sides of the coefficient
of our variable.
We divide both sides to 0.8 or 0.80, depending on how we want
to look at it.
0.80.
These are getting shorter.
So we have to find 0.8 at $ 120.
A little exercise with decimal fractions.
Let me put some zeros here.
We can multiply 0.8 and 120 by 10.
This essentially moves the decimal point
to the right with one.
And this is the same as the distribution of 8 in 1,200.
So this liver is no longer there, she is here.
This liver is now here.
8 goes to 12 once, 1 time 8 is 8.
12 minus 8 is 4, we carry the zero down.
8 is contained in 40 five times.
5 times 8 is 40, 40 minus 40 is 0, below we add another 0.
8 goes to 0 zero times, 0 times 8-grasp the idea.
0 times 8 is 0.
We have no remnant.
So our answer is $ 150.
Last year, the sum was $ 150, down 20%.
20% of $ 150 is $ 30, so the discount is $ 30, and
we definitely get
$ 120.